こっちゃんばっちゃんパークマーカーあんまで食に興味がありません肇社長です
美味しければは良いそれでいいじゃないですかそんな0起こっている私なんですけども
あの野菜の一つですねぼく通しては分からないことがありまして
きゃべっトレダスってあると思うんですよ一応買ってきたんですけども
もう僕咬み合わせてみるとどっちがキャベツどっちがいいですか現時点では分からない
んですけども
あーこれでたんですね帰ってあればそれは分かるようでもさぁ履いてないとさあ葉っぱ
や野菜キャベツとレタスを別の言葉で例えてみてください両方とも絶対緑色いう葉っぱ
が丸くなったものなんですよ
一緒や一緒や
[音楽]
一緒なんですよなええっなに何が違う何がちがうのオペラの僕アジョンって止まって
なんか味の違いいいやんとか言われても僕や剛ませんあの僕牛肉と鶏肉の違いもわから
ないくらいなんで相当ぼく何でもいいでしょうね方おいしいもな的なんですよちょっと
開けてみますわ
うわぁ
青虫が医総管ちょっと開けてみました
[音楽]
よく見たら違うないざ目の前にしてみると結構違う気がしていきましたまー
でもやっぱり同じなんですパーフェクトれたせて一生のものなんですよ犬何かが君が中
って微妙な違いがあってやっぱりねぇ私はでたちが好き私はキャベツが好きみたい幅が
できてるって言う理由は簡単になってるねあの僕がここではっきり証明しますキャベツ
とレタスが一緒だということ
いうわけでまあさすがに僕はバカじゃないんでこんだけしっかり見て違いがあるんです
よ
羽生
何けどレタスの方が咲 saki してるんですよねキャベツが方はなかったキャベツ
のシャキシャキしてるんだよな
一緒だ違いがわからんけどやっぱさせ味のチャイカがちょっと食べてみよう
水で洗った方がいいのかなと水で洗った方が良さそうと理解水で洗ってくるよ
起きれずがっちり多分洗いました
わかんないけど1枚でちょっとここにおいていきましょうかえっ
うっはー
あー cocco 容易ではないかよいではないか
あー容易ではないか良いんじゃないか
空気を入れないかよいではないかうっおいではないかよいではないか入ってでキャベツ
とレタスをちょっと準備しました
鉄拳食べてみていいかキャベツ食べます
[音楽]
1食べます
大
いや一緒なんですってことなんですけどもさせがになタイマーくって見てあーマジで
違うなと思ったんですけどもいいでしょうこれで僕が持ちこれで僕がもしこれだけで
てるんで倒れたとき別項食ってたらだかわかんなくなると思うんですよ僕は信玄に
どっちかもう答えます味もしっかり覚えました当たると思うんですけども
も力に間違えた場合これは
僕の墓勝田別とレタスが入っ小説が成立してしまうという動画になっております
ちょっと新人に当てにいくんですけども持ち間違えたら皆さん
キャベツとレタスは一生として覚えておいてくださいでは行きましょう
[音楽]
ん
うわぁカラーくなってしまったぜやはり急に視覚バレたら俺はキャベツ
[音楽]
食べ2
ね立つ
矢部いけるぞいけるぞ
いやーこれ普通なんだろうな多分
やめちゃうん
はぁ
[音楽]
めちゃ別
use
me
ああっあった
や多分これ場所ですね猫の茎のキャベツの茎の部分の中と結構硬いから
で出すと違うんですけどねこの葉っぱの部分こっからへんとかだと
れたといっしょなんででやっぱ v 的には一緒なんだと思いますねはい
えっ